bonjour alexis merci beaucoup d'être ce
matin en direct sur rt france alors on a
eu ce sondage les français jugent les
républicains soient trop proche de la
république en marche soit trop proche du
rassemblement national
est ce que ça pourrait être un sujet
d'inquiétude au sein du parti pour pour
son avenir notamment
oui alors en ce moment on voit bien que
c'est un sujet d'inquiétude et on
pourrait même dire en utilisant la
formule de jacques chirac notre maison
brûle pour les républicains alors ce
samedi pas de la planète mais de la
maison commune qui avait réussi à
construire
l'ancien président autour du rpr puis au
tour de l'ump avec nicolas sarkozy on
voit les différentes branches de cette
famille de la droite française se
séparer à nouveau avec d'un côté ceux
qui avaient déjà étaient en marche du
côté des juppéiste du côté des
centristes et puis les autres ceux de la
droite plus dur qui eux souhaiteraient
faire une cassure et sont clairement
dans l'opposition emmanuel macron or
qu'est ce qu'on voit en région paca
renaud muselier qui fait une liste en
accord quasiment avec jean castex qui
lui est premier ministre et pourtant
issus de cette formation politique
christian estrosi qui clairement a
rejoint également étonné le maquereau
par ce qui est pour lui c'est
inacceptable que le rassemblement
national puisse gagner une région et
puis on a au gouvernement déjà de
nombreux représentants des républicains
gérald arman à l'intérieur bruno le
maire à l'économie pas des moindres on a
eu edouard philippe ancien premier
ministre et d'autres qui comme ça sont
en train de se demander si ce nouveau
centre droit inventé par mena de mâcon
qui n'est plus du tout en même temps qui
est clairement maintenant un candidat de
droite
on le voit sur les thématiques qui l'a
choisie sur la façon dont ils recrutent
aujourd'hui fait que cette famille
politique dlr est bien est tiraillé
entre d'un côté le rassemblement
national et ses idées qui sont celles
aussi qui était celle du rpr notamment
sur l'immigration sur le travail sur sur
d'autres d'autres questions et les magic
en marche ce parti de centre qui aspire
tout sur son passage
on veut en venir à cette enquête de
police sur les emplois fictifs au
parlement européen qui accuse
une le pen d'enrichissement et
détournements est ce pour vous un
événement qui pourrait changer la donne
pour la présidentielle de 2000 22 alors
changer la donne c'est pas sûr du tout
parce qu'en réalité cette procédure a
pris du temps elle a été retardée par
les nombreux recours de marine le pen va
les rendre saint-just qui était
trésorier du rassemblement national et
du parti lui-même donc un procès ou même
une audience avant l'élection de 2022
paraît impossible
et puis c'est cette histoire de
détournement d'argent via des assistants
parlementaires au parlement européen
marine le pen n'est pas la seule à être
accusé il ya également françois bayrou
qui n'a pas pu être ministre de la
justice pour cette même raison et son
parti le modem accusé d'avoir fait à peu
près la même chose au parlement européen
est aujourd'hui françois bayrou et mis
lé commissaire au plan et c'est un des
soutiens essentiel des monnaies de mâcon
pour 2022 dont pour marine le pen
on voit bien que ça ne risque pas
d'aboutir sur le plan juridique après la
question c'est sur le plan de l'image
la campagne a commencé t on le voit bien
avec l'idée de salir un peu les
opposants de trouver toutes les des
affaires possibles et imaginables pour
diminuer la position de force de marine
le pen qui est en train effectivement
d'attirer une certaine partie de
l'électorat de droite traditionnelle
voire de certains de ses cadres qui
serait prêt à rallier son parti on a vu
la déclaration de nadine morano qui dira
ne pas voter dans sa région pour le
candidat dlr en tout en disant qu' elle
n'est pas contre le rassemblement
national puisqu'elle travaille au
parlement européen avec les élus de ce
groupe issu du rassemblement national
donc on voit bien que derrière il ya la
petite musique des petites affaires
c'est à peu près tout ce qui reste aussi
à la république en marche qui n'a pas
beaucoup de bilan à un bien maigre bilan
à défendre qui voudraient refaire
peut-être le coup de la sphère fillon en
2017 en sortant une affaire juridique
pendant la campagne ont pendant que la
campagne bat son plein au juste avant
l'élection
ce qui est vraiment le degré zéro de la
politique enfin ça devient un classique
vous avez raison peut-on dire que la
haye la campagne pour la présidentielle
a déjà commencé en parallèle de la
campagne pour les régionales alors ça
oui clairement on voit bien avec
d'ailleurs cette affaire qui fait la une
du journal du
dimanche c'est pour ça qu'on en parle mr
d'autres affaires non pas forcément
faire la une avec également la mise en
scène du ministre de la justice
dupond moretti qui collaient des
affiches en costume dans le nord cette
mise en scène du pouvoir puisqu'il est
envoyé par emmanuel macron pour faire de
l'ombre à xavier bertrand dans le nord
tout est sur la table et on voit bien
que ils tous les camps sont en train de
préparer cette campagne plus ou moins
activement la france insoumise avait
tenu un meeting dimanche avec jean luc
mélenchon qui a commencé à dérouler son
programme d'une certaine façon et
mobiliser ses troupes
et puis il ya ces régionales qui sont le
tour de chauffe avec de nombreux
ministres issus du gouvernement qui sont
candidats ou qui vont soutenir des
candidats parce que l'enjeu national est
immense la république en marche est un
parti qui ne s'est pas ancré dans dans
les régions ni dans les municipalités
elle a fait moins de 2% ou 2 points 4 %
lors des municipales
clairement le scrutin régional va être
aussi une gifle électorale pour le parti
présidentiel donc il faut trouver une
façon de sortie par le haut nationaliser
cette élection c'est le cas dans le nord
avec l'envoi de dupond moretti
et puis faire en sorte qu'après ça la
campagne commence sur les chapeaux de
roue emmanuel macron a promis une grande
consultation pour l'été il ya cette
sortie de crise sanitaire mais qui peut
être contrariée comme en grande bretagne
avec l'arrivée de variants et puis les
affaires qui vont commencer et la
campagne sera sans doute torride cet été
eh bien on va suivre cela merci beaucoup
à alexis poulain c'est l édito du lundi
dans la matinale d'ayrté france